♪♪
Gaal:
I think I can feel the future.
♪♪
Salvor:
I sort of know things, like I
knew to find you.
♪♪
Queen Sareth:
I intend to find out the truth
about my family
Queen Sareth:
one way or another.
♪♪
Demerzel:
I can already see that wonderful
things lie ahead.
David Goyer:
It was important to me that
Foundation be a show for a global audience
and that the entirety of that
global audience see themselves
reflected.
David Goyer:
It allows us to tell some
stories that are not traditionally told on screen.
David Goyer:
And these powerful characters
are integral to the Foundation saga.
♪♪
Season one Gaal is very young
and learning.
Lou Llobell:
Season two she’s a lot more in
control.
Gaal Dornick:
There are things happening here
that you don’t understand
and right now you just need to
accept that.
I’ve found a lot more confidence
this season.
Lou Llobell:
I look at myself in those first
episodes in season one and
Lou Llobell:
I look at some of the stuff I’m
doing now,
Lou Llobell:
and I can’t quite
believe that it’s the same person and it’s me.
Lou Llobell:
So, it is so fun to watch myself
grow as much as Gaal.
Salvor Hardin:
My name
is Salvor Hardin.
I’m your daughter.
Salvor Hardin?
I definitely wanted her to be
somebody that people looked up
to.
Leah Harvey:
It’s nice to play somebody who’s
got a really wholesome
Leah Harvey:
heart and real determination.
♪♪
Leah Harvey:
In season one she’s not very
confident
Leah Harvey:
about the things that make her
different,
Leah Harvey:
but in season two she’s gone
through a
metamorphosis of appreciating
her differences and seeing
strength in them.
Never let your sense of morals
prevent you from doing what’s
right.
Gaal unexpectedly is reunited
with this daughter that she
didn’t know she had
David Goyer:
and her daughter Salvor is
biologically older than she is.
Lou Llobell:
Finding out she has a daughter.
Dealing with the fact that she
hasn’t raised her daughter.
Lou Llobell:
There’s so many factors that are
effecting the way that she is
trying to interact with Salvor.
It’s not the rosy reunion that
one would expect.
They’ve got to earn that
relationship.
Demerzel:
I will always be here,
as I always have been.
David Goyer:
In season two, we start to
explore Demerzel’s relationship to Empire.
David Goyer:
Is she a captive or a captor?
Is she actually pulling the
strings of Empire?
We see Demerzel leading Day
where she wants to, and we get
to see a little
Laura Birn:
glimpse of how much power she
holds over him.
Laura Birn:
She dreams of freedom and at the
same time
her programming prevents her
from that dream coming true.
Laura Birn:
That conflict is haunting.
Demerzel:
I’m left to wonder
if it weren’t for this
directive, would my feelings be the same?
Demerzel:
Would I feel anything?
There are a lot of new
characters who are gonna
change the course of the show.
Will you serve me?
I will serve Empire.
Alex Graves:
Queen Sareth has been chosen by
Day to be his bride.
She brings a lot of feminine
power and energy into
what is a very male dominated
space.
Day feels that he can steam-roll
her,
David Goyer:
but she turns out to be a quite
adept political
David Goyer:
operative who really gives him a
run for his money.
It’s just a classic case of
never judge a book by it’s
cover.
Ella-Rae Smith:
Just because a woman comes in
wearing high heels and a flirty dress
doesn’t mean she’s not gonna to
ruin your life.
Should I speak first, or will
you?
Poly Verisof:
Constant!
Brother Constant is a novice
in the Church of the Galactic
Spirit.
She bounces around the galaxy
and the outer reach
trying to evangelize the people
to the way of the Foundation.
Isabella Laughland:
She's got a real sense of who
she is,
Isabella Laughland:
and I think people sort of
mistake her as a young girl.
And she's not at all.
Isabella Laughland:
She doesn't take any crap from
anyone.
♪♪
(Door opens)
Tellem Bond is an antagonist we
created for this series.
She will do whatever it takes
for eternal life.
You are singular Gaal Dornick.
Rachel House:
She’s never come across anybody
as powerful as Gaal,
Rachel House:
who can see the future.
She may be a villain,
David Goyer:
she may not be a villain.
Salvor Hardin:
Buckle up.
Season 2 is incredible.
It really feels that David and
the team have just thrown
everything at this series.
Do it!
(Explosion)
There’s so many amazing people
this season.
Lou Llobell:
The casting and the storyline is
perfect
and I just can’t wait to share
it with everyone.
♪♪
We will be ready.